welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka a friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this
episode were breaking down one of my
favorite MCU movies that is a spider-man
homecoming watching the webhead wall
crawl his way back over to marvel in
Civil War was one of the most exciting
times to be an MCU maniac and the
character's first solo movie has a lot -
impact from it throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down all of
the insane details and Easter eggs that
you only really know it's after binge
watching the rest of the Infinity Saga
this doesn't contain every single detail
in the film but there are a lot that I
haven't seen mentioned on any of their
lists so make sure you stick around
until the end obviously there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check out the movie yet
that I highly recommend that you check
out now make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
and please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
the content without the way thank you
for cooking this and let's get into our
breakdown of homecoming okay so the
movie opens in the wake of the Battle of
New York with Adrian Toomes showing off
his child's drawing of the Avengers we
later learn that this was made by Liz
and Adrian remarking on her talent is
the first clue we get that the two are
related
this scene pulls back to show a stock
tower with the a left is all that
remains on the sign this was shown at
the end of the Avengers and as we know
the location was later renamed to
Avengers tower tombs his crew are
salvaging scraps from the Chitauri
invasion in Central Station and we
actually see the Leviathan that Thor and
the Hulk killed in Avengers as part of
the main focal point of the area we're
introduced to damage control which are
actually a fictional construction
company from the comics the vendetta
between tombs in stock is set up here
and we also get a subtle hint that
they're opposites to one another tooms
is theme that we can hear introduced in
the background here is actually the same
as the Avengers but in minor tonality
which shows how he's a darker version of
the hero Adrian is really a blue-collar
worker that felt screwed over by the 1%
and thus he took things into his own
hands and rejected the idea that he
should always be a second-class citizen
that has no control over his destiny the
people in the opening are shown is
literally having to deal with the trash
left behind by the Avengers while stony
profits off it and it makes the villain
one of the most relatable characters in
the entire MCU we jump forward a yes but
this this messes with my OCD a bit as
civil war takes place four years after
Avengers which happens in 2012 if this
time Jim was right then that would mean
that this movie takes place in 2020
instead of 2016 I kind of wish they
would just replace this title card like
come on Manny you added new scenes for
Star Wars and Disney Plus so someone
couldn't just replace this one time
anyway never mind we jump to Peter and
see the trip to Berlin from his point of
view in civil war Peter gets given a new
Sunna briefcase which could be a
reference to Iron Man 2 in which Tony
gets his new suit out of a case called
the football Peter jumps into the fight
and this scene lines up perfectly with a
battle from Civil War we also see the
bruises that Tony receives in that film
namely his black eye in the exact same
place Tony calls happy for head of
security which is a callback to the joy
he did to the character in Iron Man 3
and he rejects Peters hug as he leans
over this hug would later come to get
some closure on it as when Tony and
Peter reunite in endgame the first thing
that the Fulmer does is hug him you also
see a hint of peter's spider-sense
starting to develop as just before happy
is about to hit a car Peter looks back
and forth nervously and then HAP honks
the horn before missing the collision
flash forward two months and we see
Peter texting happy buddies getting
blanked now a cool little detail here is
that Peters phone has a crack on it and
throughout the movie it gets more and
more damaged eventually leaving the
screen looking like a spider's web Peter
mentions quitting band practice in his
message and later in the film when Tony
asks what he's up to on the ferry he
says that he's he's out band practice
Tony says happy told me quit six weeks
ago so it's just a nice little subtle
callback to this message now what's
interesting is that happy pretty much
ignores Peter throughout the movie in
thematic terms Peter is very much a
mirror of tombs who was too overlooked
by the star company and its employees
they finally pay attention when Peter
kicks up enough noise which is similar
to the vulture who flies under the radar
all of the time I think Tony and happy
at the end of the movie do you sort of
regret
paying attention to be there and through
the turn of the vulture they realize
that if you don't keep your eyes on the
little things then it can blow up in
your face spiders are of course little
creatures that we often overlook so even
the name of the hero
Fitz's name and how he's viewed vultures
are also scavengers and the vulture is a
scavenger in this film so yeah great job
marvel at school Peter walks past a
mural of famous inventors from time and
we can actually see how it's stark in
the background it - played by John
Slattery Bruce Banner also appears in a
lineup of famous scientists at one point
and this world building really shows how
much effort Marvel put into their movies
we also see the principal catching a
drone in the scene and telling a student
to go to his office this is Kenneth Choi
who also played Jim Morita and Captain
America the First Avenger we can
actually see a photograph of Jim in his
office at one point showing that the two
characters are actually related speaking
of returning cast members Peters science
teacher is also the same one that we see
is a student in the Incredible Hulk I
love these moments as they really flesh
out the MCU and show their characters
often return in surprising and
unexpected ways Ned tells Peter that
he's gonna go to beat his home that
night so that the two can build the Lego
Death Star but Peters distracted by Liz
and he agrees to it without even
thinking thus he doesn't really know
that Ned will be there on the night and
accidentally reveals that he's
spider-man to him go to the classroom
and the teacher is asking them how you
calculate linear acceleration between
two points flash gets the equation wrong
and the teacher asks if Peter is still
with them as he sat watching videos of
himself on his laptop we see that the
equation actually involves something
that looks like a pendulum swing and
even though Peter hasn't been paying
attention he still works the answer out
pretty quickly this is because he's so
used to swinging through the city and
quickly working our angles that he has
no problem handling the math behind it
we can see that the video he was
watching was uploaded by Rocket Robinson
67 and this is a reference to Robbie
Robertson who debuted in 1967 we see how
Peter makes his web fluid and then cut
to him and Ned looking over to Liz and
Betty hanging up the homecoming sign
though Peter stares at Liz
Ned actually stares at Betty and this
would pay off in far from home when the
two end up dating
MJ interrupts this and we can see that
she has a pile of books throughout this
movie you might know as she reads
several and these loci handout why she's
interested in spider-man one of the
books is of Human Bondage which is about
an orphan boy that ends up living with
his auntie and uncle and the other is
invitation to a beheading that is about
a man that has been sentenced to hang
and he sits in his cell with only a
spider to keep him company cut to the
Decathlon team and we see the group
practicing questions flash sits there
mocking Peter but behind him we can see
a number of school team signs the team
is clearly called the Tigers and for a
split second in the movie we even see
the tiger mascot running through the
halls pretty much every signers go get
him Tigers written on it and go get em
tiger is a famous phrase that Mary Jane
said to Peter in the comics flash also
says that he has a date with Black Widow
and Peter heads the deli to get a
sandwich he asks for it smushed down
real flat and we later see him eating it
now if there's one thing I know it's
sandwiches and I think that he asked for
it smushed down real flat to stop the
ingredients falling out as he swings
through the city peter webs his bag up
and we later find out that this got
taken away when the bin got emptied this
is why Peter can later be seen carrying
his books instead of having them in his
bag now if you slowed down him putting
on his web-shooters
you can also see that he has a
percentage sign on the right hand side
showing how much fluid he has in the
corage layer when he runs out of webbing
we get a warning and can see that it's
on 0% we also get a Stan Lee cameo and
then Peter stops an ATM robbery that's
been carried out by people in Avengers
masks there's also a sign in the
background that says identity theft we
have you covered which PS stands in
front of obviously these robbers are
going under the identities of the
Avengers and hey nice little nice little
nod to what's happening in this scene
Peter says to Thor that he thought he'd
be more handsome in person and later in
infinity war when stola says he met the
character he makes sure everyone knows
that he wasn't that good-looking pierre
at this point gives him a funny look and
I'm just saying chris hemsworth is a
good-looking dude now one of the cool
things that you might not have noticed
is that Peter doesn't actually punch
anyone in the entire movie he has
incredible strength
paying someone could probably leave
their face looking like Deadpool so
instead he uses his webs to make
everyone either hit the people around
them or to throw them into things Peter
is attacked with the gravity gun and he
grips the floor but it rips up the
paneling however when he gets slammed
back into it he grips the concrete
underneath and thus doesn't get pulled
up cut to Avengers tower and we see
happy and Tony's robot arm dummy dummy
is often the butt of the joke and sadly
he is no different we actually learned
in Ironman that this was the first thing
that Tony ever built and it's good to
see him making a return even if everyone
hates it
don't worry though dummy I still love
you Peter and Mego to get lob and I love
this scene thank you very much we also
see spider-man climbing out of a
portaloo on the news which is held up in
a news article at the beginning of far
from home and may say she's not a fan of
Tony Stark and tells Peter that he
should trust his instincts this might
actually set up his spider sense and how
the character learns to embrace it
throughout the movies cut to Ned asking
Peter lots of questions namely if he
spits venom this is of course a nod to
want to Pete as big as foes who we learn
last year is now going to be part of the
MCU Ned also says he would stand on a
building and shoot his webs to see how
far they would go and this is a nod to
Tobey Maguire doing the same thing in
the Raimi trilogy this is also another
nod to the Raimi movies when vulture
attacks Peter with the glider Peter
jumps over it just like how he did when
fighting the Green Goblin
but the vulture was smart enough to stop
it just before it hit him the list
starts crushing on spider-man and a
friend asks if she would still love him
even if he was seriously burnt Liz said
that she would love him for the person
that he is inside I think this might
also be a little reference to Deadpool
who yeah hopefully entering the MCU soon
as well they go to Liz's party after
promising that spider-man will be there
and Liz starts talking to them and then
we get the sound of broken glass in the
background and Liz goes to check on it
I my parents will kill me if anything's
broken I get up this later becomes
another clue that Liz and Adrian are
related as when tooms returns to vulture
HQ during the same night is the party
the tinkerer says that his wife keeps
texting him about a brake light I'm
guessing at the party that someone
smashed one up and this is what we heard
earlier in the movie that might be a
reach though but you know we love a good
Reacher we then see the Shocker selling
an ultra norm to none other than Aaron
Davis played by Donald Glover in comic
books this is actually Miles Morales as
uncle who we also saw in spider-man into
the spider verse in into the spider
verse Aaron's character at one point was
watching community on the TV most
notably the scene in which Donald Glover
was spider-man pajamas so Aaron was
watching the multiverse version of
himself wearing spider-man pajamas while
also being the character and yeah it's
crazy and it's also one of the best
Easter eggs I've ever seen in a film
Aaron's alter-ego is the Prowler and we
do see at one point that this is name
dropped when Peter looks up his profile
Aaron initially turns down the Ultron
gun but becomes more interested when the
Shocker pair talked about how they have
climber's something that the Prowler
uses when committing crimes a chase
ensues and Peter runs through backyards
in a scene that's a direct callback to
Ferris Bueller's Day Off which we see
playing on a TV at a party he's picked
up by the vulture who ascends into the
air and goes over the moon and what's a
callback to Keaton doing the same thing
with the batwing in Batman 1989 Peter is
rescued by Iron Man and he dries his
suit by using a heater
Iron Man says that he put everything in
his suit and in addition to the heater
we know that there's a tracker and a
parachute
throughout our MCU videos we've always
talked about how Tony learns from his
mistakes and the heater is there after
he landed in the cold wilderness of Iron
Man 3 the tracker is there in case Peter
gets kidnapped like how Tony did in the
first Iron Man movie and the parachute
is there to stop what happened to Rhodey
in Civil War potentially happening to
the webhead
we also see this parachute in infinity
war and another cool little detail is
that we can also see the suit moving
mimicking Tony it waives its hand in an
ocean 2
most order something and laid out when
we cut to Tony in India a drink is
brought to him Tony also drives an Audi
r8 Spyder in this movie which yeah that
nice little tie in at vulture HQ we get
a good look at the Shockers arm and this
is actually the same as crossbones arms
so the group might have salvaged it from
the character after he died P attracts
the vultures goons and realizes that the
decathlon in Washington is close to
where they're hiding out he goes with
the team across the country and these
school members actually show up on the
bus and infinity war showing that Marvel
reused the same cast to keep things
consistent on the road we see a sign for
the Triskelion clean up which is a
reference to Captain America the Winter
Soldier in that cap & Co crashed a
Helicarrier into the building in
Washington and thus the cleanup still
continues when practicing questions
Peter mentions the fake Marvel element
vibranium and then he and Ned work on
the suit where they removed the training
wheels protocol this gives him access to
Karen who is voiced by Jennifer Connelly
Connolly is actually the real-life wife
of Paul Bettany who voiced Jarvis before
going on to play the vision Peter gets
instant kill mode which is also a
reference to Batman I think and we can
hear the criminals talking about the
clean-up on the Triskelion which again
is a callback to the Winter Soldier
Peter fights the vulture is he pulls off
the heist and ends up getting trapped
inside the damage control truck if you
slow the footage down you can actually
see one of the matter phases rolling
about the floor near his feet and this
is why the doorway closes above him he
goes to damage control deep storage and
gets locked in there for what feels like
an eternity but was actually just 37
minutes he actually finds an Ultron head
at one point and the eyes are still
glowing red so who knows maybe the big
bad bot of the MCU will be back one day
the scene at the Washington Monument
happens and we see Peter running there
in scene that summit house Sam and cap
did at the start of the Winter Soldier
okay that's a Reacher I admit that's a
reach you got you got me
pS saves the group in the elevator and
we cut to Adrian watching a report of
the scene on the news clearly he knows
his daughter is in Washington so it
seems really worried by it which could
be seen as a clue that liz is his
daughter for
him we cut immediately to Liz's mom
hugging Liz hinting at the connection
between the two is definitely a reach
Peter gets detention and then runs out
and goes to his locker
before lifting them all up we can
actually see scrapes on the wall above
them showing that he's done this several
times he goes to interrogate Aaron who
mentions his nephew who as we know from
the comic books is Miles Morales now
there is a theory that Miles survived
the snap and that is gonna be brought
into the MCU roughly about the same age
as Peter if not older but keep your eyes
peeled on whether that's true or not
on the ferry Peter comes across Matt
Gorgon and we can see that Charon flags
up that he is a scorpion tattoo on his
neck Gorgon and scorpion are one in the
same and I really hope that the little
tease we got from Michael mono on
Instagram means he's gonna be in the
third Spidey movie when fighting the
group Spidey also does the exact same
role that capped it in Civil War
showing that the webhead learned it from
him I know we mentioned that in our
Civil War video but it's such a cool of
V Taylor I couldn't miss it out this
breakdown the ferry is torn apart and
Peter pulls it together in a move that's
referenced in the opening of into the
spider verse the passengers are saved by
Tony and I have to say I absolutely love
this suit the thing it might be my
favorite version you know I even spent
$40 to get a funk of it and it was just
basically this the Civil War suit but
repainted anyway make sure you join my
patreon or wherever now peter gets his
suit taken away it's time to build a
Death Star from earlier and he actually
seems a lot happier he even does a
handshake with Ned that's the same one
that miles does it during into the
spider-verse he gets a date with Liz and
goes to pick her up which is when we
discover that tooms is the vulture tooms
also discovers that Peter is spider-man
and this light bulb moment is
subliminally handed out as the traffic
light turns to green when the penny
drops
after being dropped off Peter leaves the
prom to stop him from robbing stock
happy discusses how they're loading the
old Hulk Buster armor something that
would be replaced infinity war and caps
new shield which we discovered an
endgame at Tony had made for the
character even though they weren't
really on speaking terms
Peter conference Adrian and tomb says
he's sorry before he brings the building
crashing down on his head this moment is
important because
the sari catches Peter off guard and
almost leads to him being killed Peter
clearly learned from this as in far from
home Mysterio says it to him before he
tries to kill a character but Peter
manages to stop it
Toombs also takes out the structural
joints as we previously know he worked
in construction so he would know how to
do this in order to bring the building
down Peter sees his reflection in the
water with half the mask and his face
which is iconography that's followed the
webhead throughout his rich history he
also lifts the rubble similar to how the
character did in the comic the final
chapter Peter stops the vulture from
rubbing the plane and whenever I watch
this I always think that they might have
ripped off the Batman scene and rebirth
when the Dark Knight had to stop one
from crashing into Gotham I don't know
if that's a definite but it always pops
into my head so I had to mention it when
doing this breakdown when tooms is
impactful of arc reactors perhaps
suggesting that stock is built more
suits since destroying them in Iron Man
3 Peter saves vulture and thus he
decides to not rat them out to scorpion
but lives in a family are forced to move
away and Tony takes Peter upstate they
mentioned how vision isn't big on doors
which is a nod to civil war now we're
diella I've seen pointed out a fair bit
is that pepper wears the same t-shirt in
bed in Iron Man 3 as Peters in this film
and I do kind of wonder what's going on
here it's a very strange thing to put in
your movie for a number of reasons
anyway never mind Peter turns down the
iron spider suit but it of course pops
back up in infinity war in order to make
it so the press don't waste their time
Tony does a grand gesture and proposes
to pepper pepper is seen wearing this
engagement ring and IW and the movie
closes out with Aunt May discovering
that Peter is spider-man this reveal of
his identity is mirrored at the end of
far from home when it's shown to the
world and he says what the eff just like
how Aunt May does here a post-credits
scene that happens with the vulture and
scorpion meeting in prison potentially
teasing the sinister six who and that's
our list thank you for sticking around
until the end sometimes your patience
isn't rewarded but I hope it was this
time obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the breakdown and if we
missed anything that should have made
the list
comment below and let us know and make
sure you check out our analysis of into
the spider verse which talks about all
of the best Easter eggs in the movie
it's one of our greatest videos ever so
I definitely recommend that you check it
out after this if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you and I said
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep a date with the channel so
hopefully we see over there very soon
[Music]